oh
these are the faces of new patients
who've contacted Sky News since our
initial investigation independent of one
another 30 more youngsters have come
forward once again they say they were
failed by the care they received
they all went to mental health units run
by a single provider the hanticum group
now run by Active Care Group I thought I
went there to be kept safe
amongst those who got in touch are Tyson
Vickers and his mother Rachel I could
see that he was getting a lot worse we
were seeing much more self-harm how
would you describe Tyson when he went in
compared to how he was when he came out
he had cuts on his arms he was bandaged
up on both arms I mean he looked like
he'd been in a car crash
sixteen-year-old Tyson is autistic his
two months at the maidenhead unit in
March and April this year is not
something that's easy to talk about
like I still have experience like
flashbacks of things that happened there
what kinds of things like being
restrained
or like I end
um that's injection medication yeah I
was told by one staff member I would
never get out that I was just gonna be
like stuck there forever because I I
couldn't get help that's the first time
I've heard you say that
we gathered more than 20 testimonies for
our original investigation broadcast
nearly two months ago it raised concerns
over issues such as over-restrained and
allegations of inadequate supervision
leaving patients at increased risk of
self-harm
some of the 30 new people we've spoken
to shed these images this former patient
told us she got bruised Knuckles and
legs during restraints another took
these pictures of Blood on the walls she
says she was left alone for hours to
self-harm Ami told us when her underwear
was removed so she could be put into
anti-ligator clothing there was a male
member of Staff in the room I was
embarrassed she said it really went past
all my boundaries
another patient who didn't want to be
identified said her time at the
maidenhead unit left her traumatized
with walking difficulties and ticks she
told us of her life now I cannot live
independently
separate to our investigation we've
learned the first steps have been taken
by solicitor Mark McGee towards legal
action against the hanticum group he's
working on nine cases including the
family of a young patient who claims
they were raped by a member of staff at
the maidenhead unit Thames Valley police
are investigating this is systemic
systemic failure and its gross systemic
neglect all of these individuals have
been profoundly affected in terms of the
abuse that they've sustained and it was
it is going to affect the rest of their
lives Active Care Group took over the
hauntigam group in December 2021 a
spokesperson said we are very sad and
concerned to hear about these patient
experiences and allegations of poor care
a handful of which relate to time in our
care our policies and clinical
interventions are in line with national
guidelines and best practice
the previous owner's Ellie Investments
Group said it regrets Specialist Care
Services failed to meet the expected
standards for high quality Care NHS
England says in recent weeks current
patients have been spoken to and where
necessary action will be taken Lisa
Holland Sky News